Dora straight for dinner if you think  you know door she'll grow out of it  thank you yeah hey Dora this isn't the  jungle it's high school it's life or  death  so if I don't talk to you don't take a  person okay well it's trying to I've  icicles a horrible nightmare are you I'm  glad you brought it I'm just kidding I  don't actually care we're onto something  big Dora an ancient city made of gold  we're gonna break some rules we're  coming with you Prima  oh look Dora on a knife on the field  trip everybody  it's a jungle puzzle  putting lovers  the jungle is perfectly safe  [Music]  seriously you had that in your backpack  too  Dora and the lost city of gold  [Music]  excuse me I ain't chili con carne  we'll be G  you